did you ever connect with the literary
like existentialist kamu uh or or people
like Hermann Hesse or
um or even Kafka
did you ever connect with those to the
same degree yeah to the same enough to
be an influence
you know you have to be deaf in some
fundamental sense not to encounters a
great dead friend and failed to learn
you know and and I mean I tried to
separate the wheat from the chaff when I
read you know when I read all the great
clinicians all of them perhaps not
those who are foremost in the pantheon
and I tried to pull out what I could and
that was a lot I learned a lot from
Freud I learned a lot from Rogers and I
learned a lot from well from Dostoevsky
and Nietzsche I'm going to do a course
on Dostoevsky and Nietzsche for this
Peterson Academy this is coming up in
January oh that would be that I'm really
looking forward to it you're weaving
I hadn't thought about doing them
together oh that'd be fun that's a good
idea
uh there's an issue that idea you often
weave them together really masterfully
because there is a there is religious
in the broad sense of that word themes
throughout the writing of both yeah
there is uncanny parallelisms in their
writing and their lives
so
um
and dostoevsky's deeper than Nietzsche
but that's because he was a
writer of fiction Nietzsche is almost
the character and it does he is
definitely that he is definitely that
yes
apparently Nietzsche knew about
Dostoevsky than people had thought
there's been some recent scholarship on
that grounds Dostoevsky didn't know
anything about Nietzsche as far as I
know I could be wrong about that but the
thing that Dostoevsky had over Nietzsche
is Nietzsche had to make things
propositional in some real sense because
he was a philosopher and it's hard to
propositionalize things that are outside
your Ken but you can characterize them
and so in the brothers karamazo of Ivan
is a more
developed character than eliosha in in
in the explicit sense he can make better
arguments but elosha wins like Michigan
because he's the better man and
Dostoevsky can show that in the actions
right
he can't render it entirely
propositional but that's probably
because what's good can't be rendered
entirely propositional and so Dostoevsky
had that edge over Nietzsche I said well
Ivan is This brilliant rationalist
atheist materialist and puts forward an
argument on that front that's still
unparalleled as far as I'm concerned and
overwhelms eliosha who cannot respond
but eliosha is still the better man
so which is very interesting you know
that well you know the funny thing about
those two characters is you Jordan
Peterson seem to be somebody that at
least imparted embodies both
because you are one of the intellectuals
of our time rigorous and thought
but also are able to have that kind of
what would you describe if you if you
remove the religiosity of agosha
there's a
what's a good word love towards the
world Spirit of encouragement yes which
one yeah well it's it's you know one of
the things I did learn perhaps from
looking into the abyss to the degree
that I have had to or was willing to
was that at some level you have to make
a fundamental statement of faith when
God creates the world after each day he
says he saw that it was good
you think well is it good it's like well
there's a tough question now you know do
you want to bring a child into a world
such as this which is a fundamental
question of whether or not it's good
it's an Act of Faith to declare that
it's good
because the evidence is ambivalent
and so then you think okay well
am I going to act as if it's good
and what would happen if I did
and maybe the answer to that is
I think this is the answer
the more you act
out the proposition that it's good
the better it gets
and so that's Dostoevsky said this is
something else
every man is not only responsible for
everything he does but for everything
everyone else does
it's like
what is that profound or are you just
insane
then you think
is what you received back proportionate
to what you deliver
and the answer to that might be yes
that's a terrifying idea man and it
certainly you can see that it's true in
some sense because people certainly
respond to you
in kind with how you treat them that's
certainly the case I mean it's a it's
terrifying and it's exciting yeah right
but that's an adventure isn't it you uh
uh yeah
you create the world
by the way you live it the the world you
experience is defined by the way you
live that world that's really that's
really interesting and then taken as a
collective we create the world together
in that way